für mehr konsum in der krise
die regierung beschließt wichtige teile
ihres konjunkturpakets mit einer
geringeren mehrwertsteuer und einem
kinderbonus angst vor einer neuen corona
welle steigende infektionszahlen in
einigen us-bundesstaaten lösen eine
debatte über den richtigen weg aus
auf dem rücken der kinder durch die
pandemie könnte die kinderarbeit in
entwicklungsländern wieder zunehmen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und herzlich
willkommen jeder blick auf die
nachrichten des heutigen freitags an
meiner seite ist wieder norbert lehmann
für den sport ein stück von mir mit
voller kraft raus aus der krise
so hat finanzminister scholz das ziel
der bundesregierung umschrieben mit
großen finanziellen einsatz die lahmende
wirtschaft wieder flott zu machen
die koalition will dass deutschland als
konjunkturlokomotive auch gleich noch
europa mitzieht konkret hat das
bundeskabinett heute unter anderem drei
große pakete beschlossen die absenkung
der mehrwertsteuer ab dem ersten juli
dann den so genannten kinder bonus von
300 euro und milliardenschwere hilfen
für krisengebeutelte unternehmen alle
details jetzt von david gebhard als das
land weitgehend stillstand in den corona
wochen hat die bundesregierung
versprechen gemacht und sich dabei ein
neues lieblingswort rausgepickt wir
wollen mit wumms aus der krise kommen
dem erforderlichen wunsch mit einem auch
echten familienpolitischen wumms nun
geht es darum dem sogenannten wumms
versprechen taten folgen zu lassen
es winken milliarden-hilfen für die
korona krisen gebeutelte wirtschaft teil
eins des hilfspakets heute im
eilverfahren durchs kabinett über
politik gibt es ja viele vorurteile und
meinung insbesondere auch die dass sie
oft zu langsam sei aber wir können auch
anders
die größte einzelmaßnahme im
konjunkturpaket besteht darin dass wir
25 milliarden euro zur verfügung stellen
um in den monaten juni juli und august
diesen mittelständlern zuschüsse zu
ihren fixen kosten zu geben
zentrale maßnahme des konjunkturpakets
neben überbrückungshilfen für kleine und
mittlere firmen die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer von 19 auf 16 im
ermäßigten satz von sieben auf fünf
die senkung ist befristet von juli bis
ende dezember
ich glaube dass das bmz von dem herr
scholz spricht
sich als ein kurzes strohfeuer entpuppen
wird und wie das mit stroh vereine ist
dass er prüft ganz schnell die
mehrwertsteuersenkung ist relativ wenig
zielgenau
wir haben die kauf vor ort gutscheine
vorgeschlagen von der
mehrwertsteuersenkung profitiert auch
amazon die jetzt schon groß profitiert
ebenfalls heute beschlossen der
kinderbonus 300 euro extra pro
kindergeldberechtigte kind kinder die
und jugendliche natürlich die
unterstützt werden mit einem
konjunkturimpuls der die kaufkraft
stärken soll der kinderbonus ist eine
grundsätzlich vernünftige entscheidung
allerdings ist ja einmalig beendet kein
strukturelles problem oder er ist damit
auch nicht nachhaltig die maßnahmen
bedürfen noch im eilverfahren der
zustimmung von bundestag und bundesrat
damit der wumms oder was es denn wird ab
ersten juli starten kann einen großen
effekt für die wirtschaft verspricht
sich die koalition von der senkung der
mehrwertsteuer
denn günstigere preise könnten dazu
animieren im nächsten halbjahr größere
anschaffungen zu tätigen
doch dabei ist ungewiss ob alle händler
die steuersenkungen auch an ihre kunden
weitergeben
christina hansen hat sich in hamburg um
gehört
das leben ist in die innenstädte
zurückgekehrt aber noch immer wird
deutlich weniger eingekauft
ob und wie der handel die
mehrwertsteuersenkung an die kunden
weitergibt ist unterschiedlich bei möbel
und autohäusern oder elektromärkten gibt
es noch keine einheitliche linie in
diesem möbelhaus zahlen die kunden ab
juli an der kasse grundsätzlich drei
prozent weniger hoffen uns natürlich
dass gerade bei größeren investitionen
schon bemerkbar machen und wir merken
auch schon dass einige kunden darauf
wert legen und erhoffen uns natürlich
dass es ein kleine kleinen schub gibt
auch die großen lebensmittelketten haben
angekündigt die senkung an die kunden
weiterzugeben wie ist aber noch nicht
klar
die gastronomie soll durch eine senkung
der umsatzsteuer gestützt werden denn
viele restaurants kämpfen ums überleben
jede hilfe die von irgendeiner seite
kommt jetzt in dem falle vom staat
brechen umsatz steuersenkungen sehen wir
als reine rettungsmaßnahme um eine um
ein überleben zu garantieren die
steuersenkungen sollen möglichst breit
wirken um die konsumfreude zu steigern
die menschen aber sind noch
zurückhaltend wir haben jetzt in den
letzten wochen sicherlich das eine oder
andere eher nicht angeschafft und das
holen wir vielleicht nach aber wegen der
mehrwertsteuer denke ich eigentlich
nicht wahrscheinlich nicht mehr als
sonst auch insofern wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht den effekt bringen
der gewalt ist von der politik erweist
sich vom preise lohnt warum nicht also
dann sollte man das auch annehmen
aber ich bin noch nicht ganz davon
überzeugt dass es an den verbraucher
abgegeben wird
denke schon dass wir uns jetzt dann auch
ein auto kaufen deswegen haben wir uns
überlegt die mehrwertsteuersenkung
beginnt in der ferienzeit aber da die
meisten deutschen wohl urlaub im eigenen
land machen wird man vielleicht trotzdem
eine wirkung bemerken tja da war doch
auch viel skepsis zu hören ob das mit
der mehrwertsteuer auch funktioniert wie
gewünscht
dazu hat auch das politbarometer
menschen befragt und deshalb wie immer
matthias fornoff mitgebracht hallo
mattia so gut wie konnte es milliarden
paket der bundesregierung denn in der
bevölkerung so an
naja ob das so wirkt wie erhofft daran
gibt es doch große zweifel
nur 13 prozent erwarten dass die senkung
der mehrwertsteuer helfen wird die
wirtschaft stark anzukurbeln
satte 85 prozent glauben das nicht
auch die erhöhte kaufprämie für
elektroautos wird mehrheitlich abgelehnt
44 prozent finden sie gut 52 prozent
aber nicht das ändert aber nichts daran
dass das konjunkturpaket insgesamt
positiv gesehen wird
mehr als zwei drittel der deutschen
finden ist gut
interessant auch dass sich das quer
durch die politischen lager zieht mit
zustimmungsraten von 60 prozent bei afg
und fdp-anhängern bis 79 prozent bei den
anhängern der spd
tja und dann gibt es ja noch das thema
reisefreiheit im sommer und der
streitpunkt kitas und schulen ja es
waren ja kitas und schulen im lockdown
wochen lang geschlossen
dann gab's öffnungen regional sehr
unterschiedlich und jetzt findet eine
mehrheit von 52 prozent dass kitas und
schulen schnell und vollständig öffnen
sollten
42 prozent sind dagegen zum thema reisen
und zur aussicht auf sommerurlaub in
europa 43 prozent freuen sich auf die
grenzöffnungen mehr als jeder zweite
aber macht sich sorgen dass gerade
dadurch die infektionszahlen wieder
steigen könnten die deutschen also hin
und hergerissen zwischen zuversicht und
sorge nach drei monaten corona krise
herzlichen dank matthias seeger noch
mehr interessante ergebnisse aus dem
politbarometer gibt es heute abend im
anschluss an das heute journal
und natürlich finden sie alle zahlen
schon jetzt im netz in unserer heute app
das land brandenburg hat erhebliche
lockerungen der korona kontakt
beschränkungen beschlossen ab montag
dürfen sich wieder mehr als zehn
menschen treffen und mitglieder aus mehr
als zwei haushalten die abstands und
hygiene regeln gelten aber weiterhin in
thüringen werden die kontakt verboten ab
morgen durch empfehlungen ersetzt
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in ganz deutschland da bleiben
die neue infektion auf einem niedrigen
niveau
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 320 menschen neu
angesteckt insgesamt registriert die
johns hopkins universität knapp
187 1000 infizierte davon gelten gut 100
71.500 als genesen 8780 menschen sind in
verbindung mit 19 gestorben so viele
menschen wie in keinem anderen land
haben sich in den usa infiziert
inzwischen sind es mehr als zwei
millionen allein gestern kamen wieder
fast 23.000 hinzu das sind landesweit
weniger als in hochzeiten in einigen
regionen allerdings steigt die zahl der
neuinfektionen wieder die börse reagiert
nervös auch wenn sich heute die kurse
wieder etwas erholten gestern war der
dow jones um 6,9 prozent eingebrochen
nicht nur an der wall street geht die
furcht vor einer neuen welle matti
wissen arizona ist ein neuer hotspot der
korona krise krankenhäuser in phoenix
und tucson kommen an ihre grenzen
allein in der letzten woche schossen die
positiv fälle um 93 prozent in die höhe
das war vorhersehbar wir hätten es
verhindern können mit den entsprechenden
maßnahmen pünktlich 14 tage nach dem
memorial day wochenende steigen die
zahlen besonders da wo die gouverneure
die ausgangssperren aufgehoben hatten
die menschen jede vorsicht fahren ließen
die alarmsignale stehen auch froh den 21
bundesstaaten mit anstieg der
infektionen bis zu 60 prozent auch in
texas die menschen sollten das nicht
leicht nehmen und denken das virus sei
unter kontrolle das ist es nicht die
verbreitung ist nicht unter kontrolle
auch nicht in oklahoma doch ausgerechnet
da will donald trump nächsten freitag
wieder in den wahlkampf starten mit fast
20.000 menschen in der arena von ca alle
teilnehmer müssen schriftlich bestätigen
dass sie trump bei einer ansteckung mit
dem virus nicht verklagen
so geht das nicht wir sind in den frühen
tagen der pandemie wenn bisher nur fünf
bis zehn prozent der bevölkerung
infiziert waren
dann haben wir noch einen langen weg vor
uns das wirklich einfach
einige städte wie nashville tennessee
verschieben nun die geplanten
geschäftseröffnungen während in florida
immer mehr vergnügungsparks aufmachen
die höheren die infektionsraten lägen
daran dass intensiver getestet werde
meint der gouverneur in den
krankenhäusern gebe es keinen anstieg
der zahl
und dann sind da noch die proteste gegen
polizeigewalt obwohl viele demonstranten
masken tragen abstand halten fehlanzeige
die folgen könnten sich bald zeigen
die social media plattform twitter hat
seit einiger zeit ihre nutzer schärfe im
blick jetzt hat das netzwerk nach
eigenen angaben mehr als 170000 konnten
entfernt
die chinas regierung für propaganda
genutzt haben soll
sie hätten fehlinformationen verbreitet
sowie nachrichten die der agenda pekings
dienten
eine sprecherin des chinesischen
aussenministeriums wies die vorwürfe
zurück sie erklärte dass china selbst
das größte opfer von falschinformationen
sei heute ist internationaler tag gegen
kinderarbeit
dazu hat die bundesregierung heute
erklärt sie wolle den weltweiten kampf
gegen kinderarbeit zu einem schwerpunkt
der eu ratspräsidentschaft machen
kleidung schuhe café viele artikel die
auf dem europäischen markt landen werden
zuvor von kinderhänden bearbeitet oft
verdeckt durch komplizierte strukturen
in produktions und lieferprozess ein
europäisches lieferketten gesetz soll
künftig große unternehmen verpflichten
kinderarbeit auszuschließen
denn die korona krise hat die lage für
kinder weltweit noch mal verschärft wie
normen odenthal berichtet
kleine hände die schwere arbeit leisten
jeden tag sie löten und schweißen in
pakistan
sie sortieren den müll in indonesien
suchen verwertbares sie nähen textilien
in bangladesch billige kleidung für den
rest der welt kinderarbeit hat
konjunktur mehr denn je die
wirtschaftliche not ist groß eltern
haben keine wahl sie müssen ihre kinder
arbeiten schicken oft sind es sogar
professionelle menschenhändler die den
kindern jobs verschaffen das problem war
immer da aber der korona lockdown hat es
noch verschlimmert der lock down in
indien etwa die fabriken zu zigtausende
landen auf der straße verdienen kein
geld sind auf unterstützung angewiesen
und auf jeden der mithelfen kann die
familie zu ernähren monikas vater ist
krank die mutter findet keinen job mehr
als hausangestellte
ich bin in der fünften klasse aber die
schule ist zu vor dem lockdown habe ich
dort etwas zu essen bekommen jetzt
sammeln wir hier pappe die wir verkaufen
und das geld geben wir unserer mutter
damit sie uns etwas kochen kann
monikas geschichte ist eine von
unzähligen da kommt der grafik der
wassermelonen aus fährt mit denen bauern
ihr vieh füttern er trägt eine last die
kein kind tragen sollte manchmal muss
ich schieben weil meine beine nicht mehr
können
aber ich muss arbeiten sonst haben wir
kein geld
am abend bleibt ihm eine stunde zum
spielen mit freunden sagt grafik das ist
seine kindheit zurück nach deutschland
wo heute in hunderten von schulen an
anne frank erinnert wurde mit 15 jahren
starb sie im konzentrationslager bergen
belsen
mehr als zwei jahre lang hatte sich das
jüdische mädchen mit ihrer familie vor
den nazis versteckt ihr tagebuch
weltliteratur heute am anne frank tag
setzten zehntausende schüler ein zeichen
gegen antisemitismus markus gross anne
frank ein junges jüdisches mädchen zwei
jahre lebte sie versteckt und eingeengt
in einem amsterdamer hinterhaus in
ständiger angst vor entdeckung in ihrem
tagebuch hat sie aufgeschrieben was es
heißt angefeindet und verfolgt zu werden
diskriminierung und vorurteile auch
heute allgegenwärtig die sechsklässler
der anne frank schule in berlin haben
ein ganzes schuljahr material gesammelt
diskutiert und gemalt was lässt sich aus
der geschichte lernen
ich habe mich auch gefragt warum man so
was angefangen hat weil es nützt ja auch
niemanden irgendwas wenn es juden
getötet werden oder menschen die eine
andere hautfarbe haben was freiheit
bedeutet nicht nicht sich irgendwo
verstecken und angst haben
man soll einfach zusammenhalten kein
diskriminieren für das was er ist ein
fröhliches mädchen mit düsteren
vorahnungen es beklemmt mich dass wir
niemals hinaus dürfen und ich habe große
angst dass wir entdeckt und dann
erschossen werden notiert sie 1942 in
ihr tagebuch
die geschichte der anne frank steht für
die grausamkeit des holocaust ihr
schicksal bewegt und mahnt bis in die
gegenwart
anne frank hat uns aufgezeigt wie
wichtig es ist zu kämpfen jeden tag für
eine bessere gesellschaft und diese
herausforderung diese verantwortung auch
heute wahr zu nehmen damit wir alle
gemeinsam in freiheit ohne hass ohne
diskriminierung ohne ausgrenzung leben
können das ist das was wir in anne frank
bis heute lernen können der anne frank
tag soll ein zeichen setzen für vielfalt
und toleranz eine botschaft wohl auch
ganz in ihrem sinne
die französische insel korsika bereitet
sich wie viele andere regionen auf die
rückkehr der touristen vor
doch jetzt haben gewitter und starkregen
auf der insel teilweise zu chaos geführt
besonders betroffen war die hafenstadt
axioo anwohner mussten vom balkon aus
mit ansehen wie die eigenen autos
weggespült wurden
der zugang zur stadt war wegen der
überflutungen vorübergehend gesperrt
etwa 200 menschen wurden in sicherheit
gebracht
ja und nutze die arbeit heute abend
sollte in rom eigentlich das
eröffnungsspiel der em statt des
eigentlich aber dann kam bekanntlich
corona und die em wurde auf 2.021
verschoben verschoben hat sich ja auch
die komplette fußball bundesliga
hierzulande normalerweise wäre die
saison längst beendet jetzt gibt es noch
vier spieltage und am samstag könnte
bayern vorzeitig meister werden
voraussetzung dafür dass hansi flick mit
dem fc bayern schon morgen den 8
deutschen meistertitel nacheinander
feiern kann ist ein sieg von düsseldorf
gegen dortmund wir müssen mit unseren
mitteln mit unserem glauben voll darauf
konzentrieren das mit was holen können
gegen dortmund die münchner müssen gegen
gladbach dann morgen abend mit einer
ähnlichen leistung wie beim 4 2 sieg
gegen leverkusen vor einer woche
nachlegen im pokal halbfinale gegen
frankfurt zeigten die bayern allerdings
erste ermüdungserscheinungen und müssen
auf die gelbgesperrten robert
lewandowski und thomas müller verzichten
erstens ist eine sache wir müssen
erstmal die spiel gegen gladbach
gewinnen und noch mal es ist auch für
mich einfach gehört es dazu dass man die
sache auch sehr sehr ernst nimmt und
dann nicht schon von
von irgendwelchen feiern auch spricht
hansi flick übt sich in geduld für eine
vorzeitige meisterschaft gibt es
bekanntlich ja auch keinen extra preis
die europäischen pokalwettbewerbe müssen
auch noch abgeschlossen werden nach zdf
informationen soll das europa league
final turnier in nordrhein westfalen
stattfinden
spielorte möglicherweise köln düsseldorf
gelsenkirchen duisburg und das
finalturnier der champions league in
lissabon
corona hat die sportwelt verändert auch
das leichtathletik meeting in oslo fand
jetzt ganz anders als geplant statt ohne
zuschauer weniger athleten und mit ganz
ungewöhnlichen disziplinen impossible
games heißt das ganze und da hat gestern
ein mann aus norwegen für furore gesorgt
dieser unbedingte wille des norwegers
karsten war holm ist zu spüren den
weltrekord über die selten gelaufenen
300 meter hürden zu knacken
mit beeindruckenden schritten zieht der
24-jährige in den lauf komplett allein
auf der stadionrunde unmöglich ist hier
nichts bei den impossible games war holm
als höheren überflieger betitelte
unterbietet mit 33 78 sekunden
die 18 jahre alte weltrekord zeit von
chris rollen sind der zweifache
weltmeister über die 400 meter hürden
jetzt auch weltrekordler wird das wasser
mit ihrem einsatz fürs klima ist greta
team berg zum vorbild für millionen
menschen geworden einen spinnenforscher
der frankfurter senckenberg gesellschaft
ehrt die 17 jährige nun auf ganz
besondere weise
peter jäger hat eine neue gattung von
riesen krabben spinnen aus madagaskar
nach ihr benannt die schönberger
darunter auch die neue art schönberger
greta der forscher will so auf die
bedrohung der artenvielfalt hinweisen
und an das engagement der schwedin
erinnern
ihr kampf gegen den klimawandel sei
beeindruckend
und wie wird das wochenende nach diesen
prächtigen sommertag da kündigen sich
morgen unwetter an
mehr davon gleich von westen terry das
war's für heute
schön dass sie dabei waren claus kleber
erwartet sie um 22 uhr zum heute journal
wir sind morgen wieder der punkt 19 uhr
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein unverdächtiges
wochenende erwartet uns und das geht
schon in der kommenden nacht los mit
erster heftigeren gewittern
nach nordosten hin und da kann schon
stark regen dabei sein und ganz im
westen ziehen auch gewitter durch hier
richtung rhein und die temperaturen
sinken auf 18 grad im osten und 9 grad
im süden
morgen auf der road schraffierten fläche
da wird es zur sache gehen mit 30 40 bis
50 liter auf den quadratmeter in kurzer
zeit das bedeutet diese gewitter ziehen
sehr langsam und haben ordentlich viel
zeit sich auszutoben hagel und sturmböen
sind inklusive aber auch hier im gelb
schraffierten bereich müssen sie mit
gewittern rechnen
zum abend dann im südwesten gewitter
auch kräftig in den bereichen wo es
nicht schraffiert ist kann es auch mal
blitzen und donnern temperaturen
erreichen bis zu 31 grad im osten
die luft ist ziemlich schwül und
drückend am angenehmsten vielleicht noch
zur ostsee mit 20 grad
die nächsten tage in der nacht auf
sonntag dann heftige gewitter einmal
quer über deutschland und da ist auch
platzregen und strom und teilweise hagel
dabei im osten lockert schon wieder auf
bis 20 grad am sonntag dann quer über
deutschland schauer und gewitter und
ebenfalls mit platzregen und teilweise
hagel aber auch in diesem gelb
schraffierten bereich bis 27 grad im
osten war damit ein schöner abend